hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast
optimizing quality control electrical
records for 21 CFR part 11 compliance I
am Robert of labyrinth and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational seminar is presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and provider a
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webinar are also sponsored by
Beckman Coulter at Beckman Coulter
we are dedicated to advancing and
optimizing the laboratory for more than
80 years we have been a trusted partner
for laboratory professionals helping to
advance scientific research and patient
care we have a vital role our focus on
innovation reliability and efficiency
has led us to become the partner of
choice for clinical research and
industrial customers around the world
for more information please visit
Beckman comm the phone we get started
there are a few instructions we want to
hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment
answers welcome to you can do this by
hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left at the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get as many as we
can and we'll follow up with you if we
don't have time today want a better look
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button and we'll make sure to
resolve any issues that you may have I
would now like to introduce today's
presenter Tony Harrison Tony held the
convener ship of the ISO working group
revising ISO one four six nine eight -
one and - - microbial control and clean
rooms in the UK subject matter expert -
the ISO working group currently revising
is oh one four six four four - one and -
- for clean clarification at the
ugly a septic manufacturing chapters of
both the European GMP and the USA see
GMP documents Toni holds a bachelor's
degree in electrical and electronic
engineering and is employed by Beckman
Coulter life sciences as a senior
marketing manager experienced in water
system toc conductivity and ozone
analysis and cleanroom monitoring
systems as well as article clarification
Tony has spent the last 12 years in
applied metrology for the pharmaceutical
and healthcare and manufacturing
industries prior to that he worked for
companies providing process control
automated solutions for manufacturing
industries tony was joint editor and
that is PE guide to ozone sanitation a
pharmaceutical water system and was also
chief editor of the PHS s best practices
guides for cleanroom monitoring
Tony is a well known international
speaker and has provided educational
seminars on toc liquid particle counting
ozone sanitation for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring with no further
delay I would like to now introduce tell
me Harrison thank you very much Rob a
good morning or good afternoon to
everybody my name is Tony Harrison today
I'm going to talk about the extremely
critical quality control testing records
that of course go out with every batch
of product in the biopharmaceutical
pharmaceutical industry particularly
with a focus on the data integrity of
those records following the FDA's
guidance on the 21 CFR part 11 so
there's seven parts to the agenda today
it will last approximately 35 40 minutes
the first section is about the quality
test records and what the FDA has to say
about 21 CFR
part 11 for electronic records and then
I'll talk a little bit about manual
standard operating procedures or SOPs
that are still very much in use in the
pharmaceutical and biopharmaceutical
industry then I'll talk about electronic
SOPs and how they can help improve that
compliance to 21 CFR part 11 then talk
about how these SOPs impact on the final
product quality control in particular
for parenteral drug testing and also for
cleanroom routine environmental
monitoring records mmm the item six on
the agenda today is how to get
electronic records from QC
instrumentation especially focusing on
how some instruments have been optimized
to make that process easier and then
finally I was having the conclusion as
Rob said I'd welcome your comments and
questions today if I can't get to them
all today then I will come back to you
after at a later stage so let's look at
the first section of today's
presentation quality control test
records in electronic format and
particularly what the FDA has to say
about them and in 21 CFR part 11 the FDA
issued their own guidance to
interpreting 21 CFR part 11 which is
what we'll talk about today in one of
their parts of their guidance the FDA
talked about data integrity and they
give a definition of that and they
introduced an acronym alcoa so as far as
the FDA's interpretation of what data
and tech-tree actually means it means a
complete record which is consistent and
also has accurate data inside it so
their focus is really on making sure the
records that you're keeping the
electronic records are in fact a true
reflection of the test that was carried
out and I'm going to talk today about
the steps between taking a test and
getting the electronic record which
could actually introduce human error
which means you've got a very safe
record which unfortunately doesn't
contain accurate data so the FDA go on
to talk about the characteristics of a
complete and consistent accurate data
and its share they say that it should be
attributable which of course be legible
so you can read it it should be created
contemporaneously and it preferably
should be an original or if not a true
copy and of course it should be accurate
and this makes up the acronym Alcoa just
for those of you who like me wondered
what content contemporaneously meant in
this context that the dictionary
definition is that the record should be
made from the same time frame as the
test itself so what they're saying is
that it's it's best practice to actually
generate the electronic record of the
test data for quality control at the
time that the test is done and they're
suggesting that manual transcription of
a test results from a paper-based record
into an electronic record at a later
time and date introduces the possibility
of human error any manual transcription
of course introduces that possibility so
touch on manual standard operating
practices or standard operating
procedures SOPs unfortunately in our
industry in the pharmaceutical and
biopharmaceutical industry the use of
manual SOPs is still very rife and then
typically paper-based and the user
typically has to manually configure the
instrument carrying out the quality
control test and at the end of that
typically a paper record is produced and
it relies on the operator manually
transcribing that data at a later time
and date into an electronic format now
of course this gives those touch points
there for the user
introduced the opportunities for human
error to potentially impact on the
integrity of the data and the accuracy
of the data in that final electronic
record so if we
just take a look as an example for
routine environmental monitoring in the
cleanroom and look at the touch points
where human error could be introduced
first of all the particle counter doing
the routine environmental monitoring has
to be configured manually typically so
the number of samples that the counter
takes of each location and the time or
duration of those samples has to be
manually configured typically at each
location is reached in the particle
counters is started the sample location
label the name of the sample location
has to be manually entered into the
particle counter typically done through
a touchscreen on the particle counter
itself and of course this gives the
opportunity for manual sorry for errors
and misspellings and if you think about
it there's typically thousands of data
points taken for it for these particle
counters on the average pharmaceutical
site I was with one facility on the east
coast of the USA and the manager there
was telling me they had there
approximately 10,000 samples that they
took on their site every month so if you
are manually typing a location naming
manually configuring the counter it's a
massive opportunity for human error and
then of course the particle counting
results according to the the GMP s we
require to report those results in
counts per cubic meter so typically the
particle counter is set to run not it is
not a rule but this is what I've
observed people run them for one minute
or three minutes and average the results
but the particle counter doesn't take a
cubic meter sample in a 1-minute run it
takes a much smaller sample so you have
to multiply the results reported from
the count up to get the counts per cubic
meter that sounds fairly straightforward
but it depends if you have a mixture of
particle counters on your site then it's
the opportunity for error
does creep in and I will explain a bit
later on a very real-life example where
I saw that so as I mentioned if you have
a variety of air particle counters on
your
then this can impact the only accuracy
of the electronic record itself one of
the parts of the acronym of Alcoa from
the FDA interpretation of the 21 CFR
part 11 in this slide here you can see
we have three particle counters one of
them is a small handheld particle
counter then we've got an older version
of a net one particle counter the net
133 15 now obsolete we have a newer
version the net 1 3 2 or 4 5 which is a
high flow counter and if we look at
those instruments and look at Li the
different sample rates they sample at
and the volumes they sample and
therefore multiply they need to get two
counts per cubic meter it's very
different so the small handheld ones
actually only runs at point one cubic
feet per minute or two point eight 3
liters per minute whereas the old
obsolete net 133 15 used to run at one
cubic foot those 10 times the flow rate
of a small handheld and the modern met
1/3 three double for five there that
actually runs again at a higher flow
rate this time three point five three
cubic feet per minute and 100 liters per
minute and the reason it does float at
that speed is because it means when you
are classifying or re-qualify you can
sample an entire cubic meter which is a
EU GMP requirement for grade a zones and
you can do that in just 10 minutes
anyway so if you run these counters for
just one minute each then you get a very
different sample logging from each of
these counters so the small handheld
will only count obviously sample of
point 1 of a cubic foot in a minute
whereas the old met 133 15 with sample
10 times that amount a whole cubic foot
whereas the high flow count to the met 1
3 than before 5 were actually sample a
whole hundred liters in that one minute
so when you're multiplying the results
that the counter gives you up to get the
final counts per cubic meter you can see
the multiplication factor is very
different for each of these can
as for the other small handheld it's 353
for the old net one it's thirty five
point three and for the high flow
counter the met one three double for
five it's just a factor of ten so you
can see how if you've got a range of
different particle counters on your site
you can see how operators can get
confused and do the wrong multiplication
so if we look at those touch points
again the first thing the person has to
get who's doing environmental monitoring
or quality control we have to make sure
they got the correct
SOP they need to make sure they read and
understand the SOP and if they're doing
routine environmental monitoring then
they have to type each sample location
in through the screen on the particle
counter they have to manually configure
the particle counter for the sample time
the number of samples whether it's
averages the samples or gives raw
results and they also have to make sure
they're using the correct multiplier to
resolve report those results in cubic
meters finally once you've done your
environmental monitoring you end up with
a load of pieces of paper with all the
results from that day's sampling on
there and somebody has to manually
create these organize these printouts
and then manually transcribe them into
an electronic format the last touch
point is where the review and approval
step takes place where somebody has to
check all these records to make sure
they are accurate now this does give a
well-known problem for many sites this
is a neti a warning letter which was
issued in 2012 and it's actually written
up to us there are manufacturers
maintenance there are injectable drugs
and the FDA inspected their site and
they went through their routine
environmental monitoring data and they
discovered that in their grade A or or
class 100 areas and the surrounding
areas they were in fact 846 pieces of
environmental monitoring data missing
from the records over 2-year period so
somehow that data's got lost it maybe
was never recorded maybe wasn't
transcribed into the our twenty
format for whatever reason there's gaps
in the data and of course the FDA walk
the road a warning letter for that side
to highlight this issue needs to be
remedied so let's a little car some
instrumentation has been optimized help
us with face these challenges some
instruments like the met one counter can
actually have the electric the SOP in
electronic format inside the instrument
so you can pre configure all of the SOP
or the sampling routine you would do on
a routine daily environmental monitoring
into the particle counter itself so you
no longer relying on a paper-based
record for the SOP it will replicate
exactly what the manual SOP told you do
operator to do and then the operator
selects that SOP from the Met one it
will automatically configure the
instrument correctly for each and every
location according to what the SOP said
and the other thing is this counter will
generate an electronic record straight
from the instrument in the same
timeframe as the test so this is what
they mean by contemporaneously so this
literally will create electronic records
inside the counter and export it via a
wireless Ethernet as soon as the testing
is finished so this eliminates manual
data transcription and of course reduces
the impact of human error so this these
two things the electronic SOP and the
instantaneous creation of the electronic
record improves the accuracy of the
record and of course the Queen's of the
record has been created content really
with two key factors of in the FDA's
interpretation of 21 CFR part 11 so now
if we compare that electronic SOP to the
manual SOPs which we had previously all
the user has to do is select the
pre-configured SOP from the from the
screen on the counter the F the counter
is configured the electronic record is
created and it goes straight to touch
point two so we've reduced three manual
steps in there or for manual stress
sorry and we go straight to an
electronic record which is now ready for
review and approval
so let's have a look at our manual SOPs
can impact on final product testing and
today I'm going to focus particularly on
parental drug testing of course the it's
a very important step
final QC of a parenteral drug and the
test requirements vary from product to
product so if you have a small volume
injectable which is less than 25
milliliters and there's a requirement to
pull ten and fuels or vials together
having pulled them together you must
have a minimum pool volume of at least
25 milliliters and all the farmer
Kabir's across the world are harmonized
and saying you should take for adequate
s-- from that to pool volume of a
minimum of five milliliter each so
that's a small volume injectables if you
have large volume injectables such as IV
drip bags the sampling is different so
it requires you to create your own
sampling plan and you can sample less
than ten of these bags together when
you're doing this test and of course on
top of that we have the new guidance
from the United States Pharmacopeia USP
787 which is focused on protein based
therapeutics and in this particular case
although it's a small volume injectable
they allow you to take just a minimum
sample of one vial or ampule and it
tells you that the sample unlike the
four times five outputs that you need
for the so four times five million eggs
a loquats which you need this more
injectables it allows a minimum sample
volume for a loquats of point two
milliliters so it's very different to
the small volume injectables and the
pass/fail requirements vary from product
to product is to two so for small volume
injectables it's actually you have to
report the counts of particles per
container whereas for the large volume
injectables it actually counts per
milliliter and for the protein based
therapies although the testing is
different the County the results must be
reversed in counts per container again
so you can see it's quite a complex
picture here
she got a factory which is making a
range of different products different
potential products different volumes
some of them we freeze-dried or live
lives we need to be reconstituted before
they're tested and quite often the QC
team talked about their products in
terms of the brand name don't say it's a
small volume injectable record
personally nor reps mean or whatever the
brand name is and so it again it can be
quite confusing typically the same
facility may well be making a large
range of intravenous products drip bags
and things like that and again they can
be actually branded differently
according to where they're sold around
the world and on historical basis and so
this whole thing gets very confusing
when it comes support control testing so
touched on this already but let's just
go through the requirements for small
volume injectables as far as the United
States Pharmacopeia well in fact that
all farm could be is harmonized on this
and it says you must combine at these
ten vials and they're trying to get a
good statistical data from this having
said you must combine the ten vials the
minimum pulled combined volume from
those ten vials or ampules must be at
least 25 milliliters it does allow
dilution however you have to take that
factor the dilutions factor into account
when you're calculating the final
pass/fail test so you take your vials
combine them together take four samples
the pharmacopoeias tell us to discard
the first one which is trying to avoid
carryover from the last batch you've
tested and then it just suggests you
should have average the next three and
each sample must be five milliliters or
more so let's apply that to a couple of
fictional products now these are made of
products I apologize if anybody's using
these food truck names that I just made
them up so we've got Part A which is
called rep Zameen it's an ampule and
then the container size is 5 milliliters
now we've got product B which I again
I've made up it's a fictional product
called personally and it's in the same
size and pure 5 mil for product a when
it's given to the patients and dosage
volume is just one milliliter
whereas probably the terse Amin the
dosage given to the patient is one and a
half nerds right so let's apply these
test results and show sorry these test
methods and show just how confusing it
can be for the QC technician as I
mentioned all the pharmacopoeias are
harmonized on this so if we just focus
on this small volume injectable test
which is appropriate for these two
properties two fictional products and
the pass/fail criteria is that these
products should contain less than six
thousand particles at ten microns of
size or larger per container okay
so let's test product a the reps mean as
we said the ampule or container is five
milliliter in size so it tells us we
must combine ten ampules together but
when we do that because there's only one
nil in each one milliliter in each
ampule you only get a pool volume with
ten million so that's not enough so in
fact you have to combine 25 ampules to
get the minimum pool volume required of
25 milliliters so already we've got a
variance there between what you might
call standard practice so say
lee-wortley run this fictional test and
the results of the tests tell us that
you've got four and a half thousand
particles of 10 microns or a larger per
milliliter in those vials now is that a
pass or a fail so let's go back to our
prosperity RIA it tells us we are
allowed a maximum of six thousands of
those particles of 10 micron or larger
per container so we've got four and a
half thousand ten micron per or per mil
in those containers we're allowed six
thousand so the container we're using
here is a 5 mil container so if you take
that 5 and multiply the 4 half thousands
you end up with twenty two and a half
thousand counts per container which of
course would be a fail but is it in fact
as I said we allowed six thousand counts
per container and the dosage inside that
ampule is just one milliliter so in fact
it's not the size of the container that
counts it's the amount of the product
inside the ampule so
in fact it's four and a half thousand
counts times one milliliter which means
four and a half thousand counts to a
container so fact it's a pass not a fail
so that's reps on me now I will see it
very straightforward not too complicated
but now we've got our second problem
personally now this one the patient
dosage is 1.5 milliliter now if we do
the same thing here we combine the 10
ampules together because there's more in
each ampule you actually get 15
milliliters it's not enough for the 25
so in this case you actually have to
combine 79 pills to get get to that
minimum 25 milliliter pool volume so
instead of it being 25 for the reps I
mean it's 17 for the terseness oh you've
got variability in there say you run
this fictional test and you get four and
a half thousand counts which are 10
micron or larger we're allowed 6,000 now
is that a pass or fail per container now
allowed 6000 maximum per container now
in this case the dosage size is 1/2
milliliter so you have to multiply that
for our thousand times one half
milliliter and the result is six
thousand seven hundred fifty counts per
container so that's a fail so a test
which produces the same number of cats
turn milliliter can pass with one
product and fail with another so it's
all very complicated so as I say four at
a same number of counts per container
rep selenium passes frog be the
containers the same size but in fact it
fails because the actual patient dosage
is higher so what we've done with some
products like the battement also hacked
farm spec is we've optimized them to try
and reduce this confusing stat of
affairs so we've improved it and reduce
the human area which helps with the
accuracy of the testing so what we've
done is we put the pre-programmed
electronic SOPs or we've allowed you
sorry to pre-program your SOP into the
counter itself and the test selection
can be done by a list of your own brand
name so as you can see in the example
here put my fictitional drugs in there
reps in
uncertainty so the QC technician doesn't
need to think too much about the test
they select the product according to the
brand name and then they put through the
test and the machine itself will
actually automatically cure
calculate the pass/fail and give a
report in electronic format
contemporaneously so we've improved the
accuracy reduced human error and got a
contemporaneous result the other thing
that we've done with distance is again
looking at the compliance with 21 CFR
part 11 is we put the allow the user
interface for the actual particle
counter be on a local PC close to the
counter the instrument itself whereas
the actual database of electronic
records for this particular test can be
stored on a remote secure server which
allows the site IT team to apply the 21
CFR part 11 security to that remote
server this removes all manual data
scription and the other records are
created instantly which improves the 21
CFR part 11 compliance for accuracy and
contemporaneous results so let's just
click go back to clean room
environmental monitoring here we've
talked about the common issues about
this sometimes another issue I've been
told by particle counter users is of
course that sometimes the production
team are running a little behind and
they need to get the production finished
and they don't want the technician to
come into the cleanroom and carry out
the environmental monitoring so they ask
for the technician to to wait so
sometimes the technician can forget to
go back and do that sample in that
location there here's a real example
where I found somebody not applying the
correct multiplier to their past or
counting data in this particular case
the the SOP told the technician to take
three times one minute samples each
location to average the results and then
to record the counts in the daily
environmental monitoring report sheet
now the reason this particular
technician contacted me because they
were concerned that the results they
were seeing in there
daily record record sheet were close to
the maximum class limit at 45 microns
for the new GMP grade a clean room and
in EU GMP you are allowed a maximum of
three thousand five hundred and twenty
counts at point five microns or a larger
per cubic metre so they were getting
close to that limit and they're very
concerned and so you can see here this
is their their daily record of their
particle counting and their game very
dangerously close to that 3520 limits
now what I found when I spoke to them
was they were actually using an old
account to which at samples of just one
cubic foot for 2.8 three liters per
minute what they were doing they're
taking those three one-minute samples
and they were averaging the results but
what they were not doing was applying
the multiplier so they were reporting
counts per cubic foot instead of counts
per cubic meter and of course they
should have been multiplying those
counts per cubic foot by 35.3 so in fact
that counts they were recording were way
below what what they're actually should
have been recording in fact if they
applied the multiplier they were already
out of compliance and they'd be working
this way for six months very dangerous
so you can see how complicated it can
all be and that's why we've allowed you
to put the electronic SOP straight into
the particle counter which means you get
to select the SOP from the particle
counter screen it does all the more
configuration automatically and
contemporaneously generate an accurate
electronic record straight to your
remote server via wireless Ethernet so
let's just touch on how you get those
electronic records out to the QC
instrumentation as I mentioned many QC
particle counters particular portable
instruments for things like that still
produce a piece of paper records of
course collecting all those or
collecting all those pieces of paper is
time-consuming for one thing but across
this it's a ripe opportunity human error
to lose the pieces of paper or to forget
which piece of paper was done for each
location or
when you manually transcribe that data
into the laboratory information
management system or secure database
again it's another operator of
opportunity for human error to creep in
now what guess ta guide us to the
correct sort of electronic record they
suggest that you keep your electronic
records in a format which is easily read
so what they're suggesting is you want
to keep these records secure and safe
but at the same time you want to be able
to read them in ten years time if you
need to pull one out of the server and
look at them so it suggests they should
be in format which is readily available
and can be read on many different
platforms whether it's an Apple computer
or a Windows computer or even a smart
phone and they suggest use PDF XML or
SGS Gmail which are typical formats
which you read on many different
platforms so the instruments that are
optimized for pharmaceutical QC can
export these electronic records
contemporaneously direct from the
instrument either via a wired Ethernet
or by a wireless Ethernet particularly
for the portable instruments or some
cases via remote secure database so your
wireless Ethernet is perfect for the
routing environmental monitoring
so here the cleanroom technician is
carrying the portal particle cast around
tearing out the the environmental
monitoring using the electronic SOP
pre-programmed in the counter and
they're exporting the data via wireless
Ethernet straight to a secure server
somewhere on the network which allows
the IT team onto that site to apply the
correct security controls for 21 CFR
part 11 compliance in this particular
case here we're looking at a Hayek
instrument for the QC laboratory so this
machine's doing the final testing for
parenteral drugs and in this particular
case it's actually said you to put the
database of records on that remote
secure server so there's no records kept
on the the local PC in fact every time
each test is completed automatically in
contemporanea
it exports the results in electronic
format complete with a pass/fail
calculation to that secure server which
again allows the IT team to control the
21 CF part CFR part 11 security for that
server so I'm coming to the end of my
talk now on the conclusion we've talked
about how the FDA is giving us guidance
though they're welcoming the idea that
we would go to our client records for
our quality control data because they
think it's a good way to go but they are
warning us that there's a possibility of
getting human error as we transcribe
those those those paper-based results
into the electronic format and as I
mentioned they use the acronym Alcoa
which suggests that the electronic
record must be attributable must be
legible must be created
contemporaneously at the same time as
the test preferably an original and of
course accurate we've talked about how
manual SOPs make this a real challenge
for us because the manual instrument
configuration and the paper-based
records they generate seems to go at
odds with the FDA guidance quality
control instrumentation is typically a
capital investment so you're buying
equipment which you'll keep for maybe
fifteen or twenty years in some cases
I've seen instruments older than that so
when you're purchasing your quality
control instrumentation even if you're
not using our electronic records right
now you should consider investment in an
instrument which actually has the
opportunity to program those SOPs into
the instrument itself reducing all that
human error and it's preferable having
an instrument which will generate a
content contemporaneous record straight
from the instrument via a wired or
wireless ethernet even if you're not
doing out giant records right now it's a
good investment for the future and that
completes my talk today thank you very
much for attending I hope you found it
interesting and useful and now I am
going to take questions thank you very
much for your wonderful presentation and
before we get started with all of your
questions
a quick reminder about how to reach us
today if you'd like to submit any
questions at this time you may do so by
selecting the green Q&A button at the
lower left at the presentation window
the first question today
if the Beckman hia c9 7:03 is a record
database on the remote server for remote
secure server and so is a record
database on the remote secure server a
mirror database no at least not a mirror
I understand the question what you're
saying is are we creating a mirror of
the database kept on lehigh at 9 703 no
it's actually only one database it can
either be located only the user
interface to the instrument itself or it
can be as I said located separately on a
remote server the attraction of that is
that the instrument does the test
exports the electronic record instantly
and it means it goes to this remote
server where the IT team on the site can
implement their 21 CFR part 11 controls
thank you in your experience how
well-received are the electric SOPs with
regulatory inspectors such as the FDA
yeah so electronic records generally are
very well received by the FDA
anything that can automate testing and
reduce human interventions is typically
very well received by them by regulators
across the world okay in the FDA Ames
acronym ALC LA please explain what
contemporarily means contemporaneously
is that is a good one in the context of
quality control records what they're
saying is contemporaneously means that
the record should be curated directly
after the completion of the test so for
example the electronic record created
from the electronic SOP inside the
Beckman Coulter met one 3400 air
particle counters can be created and
transmitted and instantly after the test
thank you that's a 25 milliliter minimum
volume applied to the overall sample
container size or dosage size I didn't
understand why you wouldn't just take
the 10 Occulus a product a from the 50
milliliter total volume I'm not sure as
I fully understand that one but what I
was saying was rulebook told us we must
take a minimum of 10 vials or ampules
now if you've got sufficient volume in
each of those ampules to make up 25
milliliters which is the required tooled
volume you must take then that's fine
you just need 10 ampules or vials but if
you if you haven't as in the examples I
showed where the product a had only one
milliliter in the vial or ampule so if
you only take 10 which is the minimum
requirement you only get 10 milliliters
hence why you would have to take 25 if
you only had one milliliter inside each
ampule I hope I've answered that
correctly I wasn't sure about the
question but I hope I'll answer it
correctly thank you and what can you do
with old instruments that don't have
direct electronic records and generation
and capability other than replacing the
instrument altogether yeah unfortunately
that that is the the only way forward so
if you've got an older instrument which
which just gives you a paper printout
generally speaking there's not much you
can do with it and I have recent one
just this year in fact I've visited
several production facilities where
because of the the resistance to change
which you know we all try to not to
change things in the pharmaceutical
biopharmaceutical quality control world
the instruments we don't tend to change
them because of course that means
revalidation which is timely and costly
but I've seen sites just this year which
were using particle counters that were
made obsolete 20 years ago
and they desperately hanging on to them
because they don't want to change them
but unfortunately because they are so
old and they producing just a paper
printout the actual computing engine if
you like inside those particle counters
is not capable of generating an
electronic record it's just not powerful
enough so there's nothing much you can
do with them on Freight unfortunately
other than by the next generation from
your supplier which hopefully would
allow use for the electronic SOPs in
there and generate the electronic
records thank you
my next question can this software a
farmstead manage levey-jennings charts I
apologize can you repeat that for me
please again and oversee can this
software farm spec manage levey-jennings
charts right okay no it can't it just
literally produces the test results from
the test in electronic format it does
say pass file but it unfortunately no it
can't do that thank you
in what protections against unauthorized
changes do you have in place for the
electronic SOPs in the instruments sure
so the for instance in the mat one the
air particle count of a portable air
particle counter we we've applied
multi-level user control so you have an
administrator manager and user so only
the administrator or the manager can
actually make changes to these
electronic SOPs and typically where when
the user logs on they have a very
limited menu available on the screen
which is literary to cook that you
choose the SOP they're going to use that
day and then to run the counter there's
nothing else they can do or change on
the counter so we locked it down so once
you've pre-programmed them it locks down
as far as the user is concerned and all
they can do is is to run the counter so
that's how we control it thank you very
much
one of our viewers is attending from a
food in safety instrument developer and
is wondering whether they need to follow
21 part 11 yeah so the 21 yes the the 21
CFR part 11 is a applies to food and
drugs so like the FDA of courses Food
and Drug Administration it applies to
food and drugs so it's really anybody
who's trying to keep quality control
records in electronic format try to
apply 21 CFR part 11 whether it's food
manufacturing or whether it's promise
suit or biopharmaceutical I think it's
so very much
our last question here that we have is
most injectables and have some overages
in volume and fill to allow for bubble
casting what calculating the past sale
do you use actual injections or the
physical volume inside the vial yes so
that's a good question what you're
saying is the actual the volume of the
the solution inside the vial or the
ampule is actually slightly more than
you would give to the patient because of
course typically the the nurse or the
doctor would actually want to eject a
little bit at the sample to remove
bubbles from the syringe before they
injected into this the patient so my
interpretation of that would be
potentially you could inject the entire
volume inside the vial into the patient
depending on who's giving the injection
so potentially that entire file could be
given to the patient at one go so I
would interpret it that you should do
the calculations regarding the pass/fail
and taking into account the total volume
that's actually in that vial or ampule
so if you've allowed an extra small
amount extra over and above the dosage
that you give to the patient you need to
calculate it with the total volume
because it could be possible that
somebody won't eject the bubble so just
give the whole thing to the patient so
that's the potential
they're so you should test the entire
volume inside the vial and that's how
you base your pass/fail results and
thank you so very much I'm definitely
finding closing remarks just to say
thank you to everybody for attending
today I hope it was clear and hope I've
explained how electronic SOPs and
contemporaneously generated electronic
records from the instruments can help
remove a lot of those are opportunities
for human error in final product quality
control so thanks again for attending
well thank you very much I'd like to
claim mr. attorney Harrison today as
well as our sponsor Beckman Coulter for
making it possible for in this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 8 and you will see them
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand posted on Landon's
calm you're welcome before this
announcement to any of your colleagues
who are not able to join us today well I
want to thank you again and see you next
time
goodbye thank you rob goodbye